[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAOMI KLAMEN: I am a cloud
engineer here at Google
and been privileged to be
working with James and Vinny
here at Colgate
for the past year.
I also want to
acknowledge Chris,
who's in the audience
who's our Tam, who's
been doing a lot of the
work with us as well.
And today we're here to talk
about migration to Google Cloud
Platform that we've done with
Colgate over the last year.
We as-- for those of you
that were at the keynote
this morning, Mike Crowe,
the CIO of Colgate,
talked about a successful
implementation of SAP hybrids
on GCP installation from
scratch, which showed
the agility of GCP to Colgate.
And I'm excited to say
that this weekend, we
completed a migration of
another SAP hybrid to GCP
that is live up
and running, which
is another e-commerce site.
All exciting.
It's been a lot of
work and exciting,
and James and Vinny
are here to talk to you
and tell you about
their experiences.
One comment, though.
In some of the
sessions, I know you--
there was a Dory where you
were able to ask questions.
For various reasons we
decided not to have a Dory,
but we are here to stay
after the presentation
and answer any
questions that you have.
And so we'd love to share our
migration experiences with you.
JAMES MODICA: So good
afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to our session.
Over the next few minutes, Vinny
and I will take us through--
and that would be nice.
Thanks, Vinny.
Vinny and I will take us--
will take you through how
we're gaining agility with--
by utilizing GCP.
So as part of the agenda,
we'll go a quick overview
of who Colgate is as a company.
We'll talk about that
e-commerce implementation
that Naomi mentioned,
and we'll also
talk about how we're leveraging
Google Cloud Platform to extend
our data center
and gain agility.
So Colgate-Palmolive is a
200-plus year old company
with approximately 34,000
Colgate people worldwide.
Our products are sold
in over 200 countries,
and we sell our products
in four key categories.
We have our oral care,
pet nutrition, home care,
and personal care lines.
And as you can see, we
have some of the most
world recognizable
brands, and depending
on where you are
from in the world,
some may be more
recognizable than others.
So let's quickly
go through how we
built that new e-commerce site
for Colgate in a Google Cloud
Platform.
So we had a challenge
from the business.
It was a challenge to implement
an e-commerce solution, an SAP
e-commerce solution, from
start to pilot in three months.
So we reviewed our on
premise environment
and found that we didn't
have the hardware on premise
to support this
implementation, and we also
knew that the
hardware procurement
cycle could take up to two
months just itself on prem.
So we had to be--
we also didn't know
if it was going
to be a small medium or
large platform, so that was--
that meant we had to find
somewhere that was scalable.
So GCP was the perfect fit.
So as part of that, we also
had to integrate with our--
as part of moving
that application
or building that
application in Google,
we had to integrate with our
current on premise environment.
So we had to lay a foundation.
And part of that was building
the network connectivity.
Using Google services such
as Cloud VPN and cloud VPC,
we were able to build that
network, which gave us--
which allowed us to build
the application in Google
and provide access to
the storage and images
to run that application as
well as other back end SAP
applications.
What was good it
was that foundation
was built within a
week, and we were also
leveraging that foundation as
part of any new implementation
in Google going forward.
So it was a one-stop shopping.
So as a result, after
we built the foundation,
we were able to stand up this
whole environment in one day.
By being agile with-- by
standing up this environment,
we provided this environment
to our application teams,
and then they were
able to produce--
to install the application
and produce testing cycles
within a few days after that.
So as a result,
our IT organization
was able to meet
our business goals,
and we provided a future roadmap
for delivering rapid solutions
to the business.
So future state, we'd like
to be able to be even more
agile by using
third-party applications--
third-party providers such
as Terraform to leverage
the infrastructure as a code
and be more agile going forward.
So let me hand
you over to Vinny,
who's going to take you over
through our migration project.
VINCENT RICCI: So again
my name is Vincent Ricci.
I am the lead cloud engineer
at Colgate-Palmolive.
And today we're
going to go over some
of the foundational elements
we had to put in place
prior migrating to GCP.
So the scope of the project
was simple on paper.
We had to migrate a workload
of 1,200 Windows machines
and stay within the lift and
shift migration strategy.
We wanted to avoid
any re-architecting
or replatforming
anywhere possible.
That way we could keep our
targeted goals in place.
Early on, we partnered with
Google's professional services
organization.
They helped us move along that
journey to migrate to GCP,
We do this in a couple
of different ways.
So what we did in
the beginning is
we set up a bunch of
in-depth workshops with our
on premise support teams.
That gave us the ability
to identify how Colgate
operates on a day to day.
From there, Google was able to
produce a technical gold design
document, and that became our
true roadmap or our blueprint
going forward on
how we're actually
going to migrate to GCP.
Now within that TDD,
it was broken up
into sections of the project,
and that-- those sections were
called work streams.
We're going to go
over them in a second.
So the work streams were
broken up into four key areas.
Building the foundation was
a key part of our project.
It allowed us to build
all the technical building
blocks that were needed
before we migrated to GCP.
Second, we migrated
a pilot workload.
This gave our teams
the early access
to understand how
a migration works.
And then in parallel, we also
implemented a data center
discovery tool that analyzed
all of our connections
within our data center so we
could understand what servers
are communicating to others.
And then our final work stream
was our full Windows workload
migration.
So for this presentation,
we're actually
going to focus on the first
and third work streams.
So let's dig a little deeper
into those foundational
elements I spoke about earlier.
So the foundation really
consisted of three parts--
cloud governance, understanding
what governance policies
we needed to continue to do
in GCP while also building
new policies that were
more cloud focused.
Building a landing zone.
So this is the technical
building blocks
I spoke about earlier
and all the pieces that
were a part of that in
order to migrate to GCP.
And then we needed to
bring in some new tools,
and these tools were going to
help us go along that journey.
So in the area of
cloud governance,
a couple of questions
were asked early on
such as which servers
could be migrated
and how are we going
to manage them.
How are we going to secure
them, and how are we
going to control cost?
So in the area of
cloud readiness,
we had to come up with
a way to identify how--
we had to come up
with a way to identify
that our servers were ready.
So it's a couple of examples--
understanding how the license
structure of an application
could translate from on
premise to cloud, understanding
if the application
support from the vendor
carried over to the
same level of support
that we had on premise.
That was a key prior
migrating to GCP.
Also understanding the
amount of communication
that servers were having to
each other on premise also
was important to understand
if they were cloud ready.
In the area of infrastructure
management, what we had to do
there is understand
that we were going
to continue to use some of
our on premise applications
in the areas of patch
management and load
balancing and monitoring.
And we identified
this because we
wanted to ensure that
we didn't have a reduced
functionality of what
we currently have,
but also we wanted
to also continue
to leverage our on premise--
our company's team's
expertise and the tools
that they already know.
Now on the flip side
to that, we are also
continuing to investigate more
cloud-focused solutions to help
us along our long-term journey.
Platform security.
So Colgate is G Suite company.
So being able to integrate
with our current G Suite
implementation, we
created custom groups
that made access to
our Google Platform
for our support teams
quick and efficient.
But then for our users,
we were able to use
the power of IAM or identity
and access management
to give our users the ability
to be agile in the cloud
but also control some
more sensitive areas
that we needed
more control over.
And then finally
cost management.
We had to come up
with a way that once
we migrated to GCP, how were
we going to manage costs?
So we did that in a
couple of different ways.
By exporting our billing
information from GCP
to BigQuery, we were able to
leverage tools such as Data
Studio to build
custom dashboards
to give us the needed visibility
into our cost for our projects.
And then an area of control
we used billing alerts
within the GCP console
to notify us that when
projects reach a certain
overage in terms of their cost
structure.
So want to go a
little bit deeper
into the network
architecture and what we had
to do to be ready for Cloud.
We knew early on that we
had to keep connectivity
back to on prem with
our cloud environment,
that hybrid connectivity.
So-- and we also
wanted to make sure
that we set up our
isolated networks in a way
that we were as
secure as possible.
So originally we set up-- we
did this through multiple VPCs
for both our nonprod and
production environments.
We also configured VPNs for that
hybrid connectivity to multiple
regions in the cloud .
That way we could leverage
that global GCP network.
And then in a high--
in our higher traffic areas,
we implemented interconnects
to ensure that that
bandwidth is increased.
Now for our GCP communication,
we implemented shared VPCs
to enable our projects
within the same environment
to communicate to each other.
But in doing so we also
implemented micro segmentation.
That way servers could
communicate to other servers
only when we allow
it even if it's
sitting within the same subnet.
That gave us the highest level
of security moving forward.
So let's talk about
some of the tools
that we're using to help us
with our migration journey.
So ATAVision is an
agentless discovery tool
that we currently have
deployed in our data center.
It is helping us map our entire
server footprint of our data
center, and it's doing that
through a couple of key
is providing us a
couple of key things
in terms of technical
details so as I said,
server to server communication.
But how often is that
server communicating
to that other server.
That could help us identify
some of our top talkers
within our data center.
And as their eyes
are communicating
to each other, what kind of
protocols are they using--
TCP, UDP?
Is it inbound outbound traffic?
What ports are they using?
So implementing something
like micro segmentation,
you need to have
all that information
prior migrating to GCP.
At the end of it, having
that data center footprint
allowed us to create something
called migration move groups.
And what that basically
means is servers
that should move together
get moved together.
So for Cloud security
and compliance,
we are leveraging Security
Command Center along
with Forseti Security.
And what that's basically
allowing us to do
is put in all the
necessary rules in place
to make our GCP
environment more secure.
Once those rules
are in place, we're
not only able to sniff out
vulnerabilities of areas in GCP
but prevent them from
happening in the first place.
Other areas such as
organizational policies,
that allows us the
highest level of
controls to be put in place
that are then hierarchied down
to all of our service projects.
So I want to talk a little
bit about server migration.
The tool that we are currently
using is called Velostrata.
So once your hybrid
connectivity is in place
from your on prem environment
to your data center,
you basically have
four major steps
that you need to do when
using the Velastrata tool.
So step 1 would be to
implement your management
pieces of Velastrata.
So what that is, is an
appliance in your data center,
And That is the rightly working
with your VMware environment.
And then you have
your compute instances
running in the GCP side.
Now these two
pieces of Velastrata
are in constant sync
with each other.
They allow basically the
entire migration process
that we're going to talk
about on this slide to occur.
So once your management
pieces are in place,
we can begin the migration.
So on prem within
your V center--
your VMware environment, you're
able to execute a migration.
And what that's doing is
it's going to take the server
configuration that
you have on prem
and replicate it in
the GCP environment.
But you do have the option to
change that configuration based
on different needs.
Maybe that server on prem was
sized at a higher workload
than it needed to be.
Within a short time,
30 minutes or so,
the GCP instances
are accessible.
So that's a key point
here because you
don't have to have an
excessive amount of downtime.
You could turn over these
instances to your support teams
or your application
teams to begin
an additional configuration
or to just begin testing
of that application in GCP.
In the meantime, storage
migration begins.
So the on premise
disks will then
start to begin
streaming-- or the move--
the migrating of storage to
new disks within the GCP side.
Now depending on the
size of those disks
will correlate to the length
of that disk migration.
Once a storage
migration is finished,
you're basically ready
to do your last step.
And that step is
called a detach.
And a detach is basically
disconnecting your
on premise environment
from your GCP environment
in terms of Velastrata,
and those disks
that are now fully
migrated are now
attached to those instances.
And you're done.
That in a nutshell
is your four steps
on how to migrate your on
premise servers to GCP.
I have a couple slides
here just to wrap up
my part of the presentation.
I just want to talk about
some integration points
to consider when
possibly migrating
your environment to GCP.
So in terms of
firewall management
going to a GCP environment or
a public cloud environment,
you may want to consider a more
granular firewall management
such as micro segmentation.
But when doing so, it is
critical to understand
how your on premise
environment is communicating
like I mentioned
from our conversation
before about ATAVision.
In terms of patch
management, we might
want to consider a new
patch management strategy
when going to the cloud.
This is a great time
to think about that.
Having a pre-migration-- a
detailed pre-migration plan
where you could identify
some of the things that
might get missed during
a migration is key.
So, yes, we have
our ATAVision data.
That's our technical
data, but being
able to supplement it
with something that we
do, such as application
interviews where
we speak to the application
owners and get some insights,
that maybe a tool can't give us.
So being able to take
that technical detail
and that app owner
detail, put it together,
gives us a higher chance
or a high confidence
when migrating to GCP.
So we don't miss
something, let's say,
an application I might be
leveraging a load balancer.
IP address mapping.
So when we are implementing
hybrid environment where you're
connecting your GCP environment
to your on premise environment,
you want to make sure that
those subnets that you're
provisioning in GCP don't
conflict with your subnets
that you already have
within your data center
or globally for your company.
On the application
side, you want
to make sure that
you understand how
your applications are currently
interfacing on premise.
That's going to be key
to understand how you're
going to move not
just one application
but many applications at
a time to keep those move
groups together.
You also want to make sure
that your external storage
that your applications may use
stays intact post migration.
And then having a very good
detailed cloud compatibility
check--
that's that cloud readiness--
could help you avoid some
potential issues in the future.
Let's talk about some
post-migration benefits.
So a lot of benefits
that you hear usually
come around a net
new environment.
Someone is building
that new, and these
are all the benefits that you
get from running in the cloud.
But a lot of those benefits
also correlate over
to someone that's migrating
their servers to the cloud.
So live migration, being able
to reduce your-- or potentially
reduce your maintenance
windows by not having
to patch the physical hardware
because the live migration
is seamless to the customer.
Right sizing, leveraging
Google's recommendation engine
and artificial
intelligence to understand
when servers are
underutilized or overutilized
and then provision the correct
sizing for those servers.
Something even as simple
as hardware leases.
When migrating to the
cloud, you no longer
have to worry about
your hardware leases
and managing those schedules.
Faster provisioning,
not having to worry
about capacity planning,
which every data center has
to worry about, and using the
agility and the scalability
of the Cloud
Platform to provision
faster and basically on demand.
And then finally reduce
license management.
So leveraging Google's images
such as Windows and SQL server,
you no longer have to
worry about those licenses
and managing those licenses cost
because they are built into the
build itself.
So in a nutshell, GCP is
helping us as a company
to become more agile.
Google's professional
services are continuing
to help us grow in that sector.
And then the tools
that we're using
are helping us to get
to our destination.